okay let's go to the phones why don't we
let's go to our phone number which is
six one seven eight three zero 4750
we'll take our first caller from the
seven one seven area code caller
tell us your name where you're calling
from and what's on your mind hey my name
is Logan
I've actually called him before it was a
really nice experience I'm actually
calling up my campus right now all right
what's on your mind today Ragan so this
is kind of an interesting sci-fi ask
sort of question so what if the what if
we had sort of like a one-world order
well okay no let's backtrack a little
bit
what if like the President of the United
States was not a human being but instead
sort of like how nine thousand ask robot
yeah that can that would that would
scientifically take the polling data
from the United States and custom-tailor
so like for example like gay marriage is
popular amongst the populace of the
United States so the robot would favor
gay marriage over yeah so listen I mean
I think politics is inherently a human
thing so I don't know that I want a Hal
9000 making those decisions if we did
have a computer running the country I
can assure you the computer would know
that there is no president of the US
Virgin Islands that's for damn sure so
we can be sure Trump's no computer Logan
I appreciate it a very interesting
question and one that is fortunately not
a particularly pressing one right now
not not an issue that we are currently
contending with